JOANNA G. SMITH: Users worry
about battery constantly.
And that means that we, as
developers, should constantly
be vigilant about battery use.
So we decided to build that
vigilance into the framework.
In Marshmallow, we introduced
Doze because, at some point,
the user will probably place
the device on a coffee table
or nightstand.
This means they've
turned the screen off,
the device isn't plugged
in, but it is stationary.
So when they pick the device
up again off of that table,
their battery should not have
magically dropped by 30%.
And that's why Android will
defer background jobs and syncs
as well as alarms
and Wi-Fi scans
until a scheduled
maintenance window
so that all background
activity happens in one batch.
By having these specific
maintenance windows,
we can extend the battery
quite significantly.
But now we have extended
Doze for a more common use
case-- leaving your
phone in your pocket.
When the screen is off,
after a short while,
a light version of Doze
will trigger with a smaller
set of restrictions.
And we will have regular
maintenance windows
during this time.
But all of our advice
still applies here.
If you've done the work
to account for Doze
and app standby in
Marshmallow, you
won't need to do
anything extra now.
Note that this does not replace
Doze as it was in Marshmallow.
If the device becomes stationary
for some period of time,
the full set of restrictions
will apply again.
So it helps to understand
what the distinction is.
The lighter Doze mode
has maintenance windows
that trigger on
shorter intervals
so that your app can be
ready when the user returns
to using their device.
And wakelocks, GPS, Wi-Fi scans,
and alarms all work normally
in the lighter mode.
Here we are focusing on
background syncs and jobs
and, more generally,
network access
because these are both
large drains on the battery
while being the most
flexible things to differ
and optimize when a
user is out and about.
As expected, though, a
high-priority GCM message
is still the best way to deliver
time-critical information
to your app.
When you do, your app
gets a brief reprieve
to use the network
and see what's up.
This allows your
server to be confident
that the important
things reach the user.
And, of course, any
foreground service
will continue to work regardless
of battery optimizations.
So whether the device
is stationary or not,
if that screen has been
turned off for a while,
we intend to honor the
fact that the user isn't
engaged with the device.
And that is an opportunity
to conserve power.
So test your app to be sure
it works how you expect it to,
and consider tweaking
a few behaviors so
that you can continue
to build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]